du sport à la science à présent la fête
de la science c'est jusqu'au 14 octobre
on en parle avec nos invités nous allons
voir les rendez vous à ne pas manquer
sur saint quentin en yvelines notamment
première fête de la science 1992 vingt
ans plus tard toujours le même principe
la promouvoir auprès du grand public
expositions animations conférences du 10
au 14 octobre partout en france et dans
les yvelines
bonsoir donc atteignent lozère vous êtes
la directrice du latmos vous allez nous
dire ce que ça signifie de
l'observatoire de versailles saint
quentin en yvelines
rattaché à l'université de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines à vos côtés
flora tout et vous êtes chargé de
l'action culturelle à la maison de
l'environnement des sciences et du
développement durable de saint quentin
amélie aubert également bonsoir à vous
chargé de communication d'accueil et de
documentation dans cette même maison de
l'environnement et karine varaldo vous
êtes coordinatrice des activités pour
les petits débrouillards alors déjà
peut-être un mot général pour commencer
est ce que cette fête de la science rend
service à la science est ce que ça
permet véritablement de la vulgariser
est-ce que c'est accessible pour le
grand public quand on entend fête de la
science on pense pas forcément tout de
suite amené les gens qui n'apprécient
pas la science au quotidien on va dire
oui bien sûr enfin en tout cas c'est
notre volonté on a comme idée de faire
connaître les métiers de la science et
les résultats de la science
donc nous notre laboratoire atmosphères
milieux observations spatiales et les
animations sont proposées par les
ingénieurs par les gens du métier
les jeunes ingénieurs et chercheurs du
laboratoire et on souhaite vulgariser à
mener notamment les jeunes vers la
science et éventuellement des études et
des métiers scientifiques sur la maison
de l'environnement pour les petits
débrouillards aussi à cette semaine de
la science mais vous intervenez tout au
long de l'année sur ces questions de la
science on va le voir aussi là c'est un
moment particulier où c'est juste que
vous faites le même programme tout au
long de l'année et là on n'en parle plus
parce que c'est la fête de la science
fait la thématique des sciences
effectivement c'est vraiment le mois
d'octobre puisqu'il est à la fête de la
science à l'intérieur du 10 au 14
octobre
et donc nous n'en notre volonté c'est
vraiment de l'élargir sur un mois donc
un mois de programmation un peu partout
sur saint quentin en yvelines
mois d'octobre tous les mois d'octobre
voilà certaines comprenons les sciences
en fait on va proposer aux habitants
différentes animations des ateliers des
conférences pas mal de choses autour des
sciences donc sûre pour tous les
habitants pour tous on va parler de
votre programme on va parler des actions
aussi des petits débrouillards mais
alors on va s'intéresser à cela commence
alors vous me l'avez dit c'est
l'observatoire vous reste redire les
initiales latmos et laboratoire
atmosphères milieux observations
spatiales
donc on s'intéresse aux sciences de la
planète en général la planète terre est
également aux planètes du système
solaire donc principalement le pour
l'heure pour la terre c'est l'atmosphère
le climat et pour les planètes c'est
découvrir explorer les planètes du
système solaire dont on connaît pas
encore tous en effet quoi concrètement
alors on y fait quoi on développe vous
proposons qu'on soit en développent des
instruments et c'est ça qu'on pourra
voir chez nous dans les journées dans
ces journées de la science
on développe des instruments pour
mesurer par exemple les caractéristiques
des nuages sur la terre ou la
précipitation ou la composition de
l'atmosphère sur terre comme autour des
planètes et donc on peut y voir les
instruments qu'on a développés est
également un le robot enfin une maquette
à l'échelle 1 du robot qui a été envoyée
sur mars
sur la planète mars au mois d'août
dernier qui embarque un des instruments
qui a été développée chez nous on va
voir quelques images injustement pendant
qu'on parle de ceux de ce fameux robot
alors c'est pas le robot qui est parti
sur mars a annoncé sa maquette chez eux
on peut pas leur apporter points sont
donc ce sera possible de le découvrir
lors des portes ouvertes du côté de
mauvaise que le dimanche 14 octobre de
10h à 18h vous allez accueillir le grand
public les familles qui vont qui vont
venir vous rendez vous qui sera en
concurrence avec les autres rendez vous
de la fête de la science sur naples a
partout
un peu partout sur le département et sur
saint quentin en yvelines
là les images ont été tournées
aujourd'hui déjà il ya des enfants des
familles qui ont pu qui ont pu s'y
rendre c'était plus pour les pour les
scolaires ou les sandwichs alors laisser
ces jours-ci là c'était plutôt et
scolaires demain devant des classes
scolaires et il ya eu un groupe de 200
d'animation qui est venu ce matin
effectivement c'était sur rendez vous
aujourd'hui et dimanche c'est ouvert ça
les passionne les enfants un bus avait
passionné oui et puis voix il voit aussi
d'autres d'autres démonstrations sur des
instruments qu'utilisent les principes
optique ou d'autres principes physico
chimiques pour mesurer les par exemple
la composition de l'atmosphère les
instruments que vous utilisez j'ai
quelques noms vous dire ce à quoi ça
correspond vous travaillez avec pampres
également un passeport pendre c'est une
sorte de réacteurs fakih qui permet de
simuler des atmosphères tels qu'on les
retrouve dans des planètes en
particulier titans qui est un satellite
de saturne donc c'est un des satellites
du système du système solaire et on y
fabrique des atmosphères tel qu'on peut
rencontrer sur sur les planètes pour
essayer de comprendre comment ce sont
générés par exemple des les petites
particules qu'on trouve en suspension
dans l'atmosphère qu'on appelle les
aérosols et c'est de comprendre leurs
compositions et comment ils sont
formulés à beaucoup de choses derrière
ce simple nom pampres y en a d'autres à
un picard sam type cave alors pour
connaître tout ça il faudra se rendre
porte est ouverte et vous allez
expliquer comment cela fonctionne alors
à des ateliers 1 qui publie les
visiteurs pourront choisir ce qu'ils
souhaitent revoir ça crée véritablement
des vocations vous pensé dans quelques
années les jeunes par exemple
s'attacherait qui sont venus vous voir
vous pourrez les retrouver
j'espère que tout le monde n'est pas non
plus destiné à faire des sciences
physiques mais on espère intéresser aux
métiers et aux résultats aussi bien tout
vous avez évoqué mars avec cette
maquette du robot qui est parti sur mars
que l'on peut découvrir
rêveriez-vous d'habiter sur marcel une
de notre question du jour on vous écoute
non ça ne m'intéresse pas non pas du
tout une quête spéciale tout ça non pas
du tout moi je suis bien sur terre quand
même je pense que c'est plus intéressant
de visiter la terre que
mars pour moi cette date de fin de la
pierre quoi donc au grand dieu je suis
arrivé un temps oui pourquoi pas 100 pas
mars peut faire chaud pour découvrir
pour par curiosité je dirais oui on voit
la différence avec la terre ah non pas
du tout bah oui je suis très bien ici je
ne rêve pas d'aller sur mars
en tout cas je rêverais bien de voir à
quoi ça ressemble non il n'y a pas
d'arbres
moi j'aime les arbres l'ère des fleurs
que qui peut-être que les martiens
serait pas bon goût ou alors ils sont
comment le martien d'entre vous je ne
sais pas un peu trop minérale pour moi
sûrement pas pour quelle raison
nouveau support ça me paraît beaucoup
trop loin et voilà c'est très rationnel
forcément on va là c'est trop loin mars
ça vous fait rêver mars puisqu'on parle
de la science on vulgarise la science ce
soir ah oui complètement marre ça vous
fait rêver alors du côté de la maison de
l'environnement du développement durable
et des sciences également parce que l'on
dit moins souvent on dit souvent maison
du développement durable maison de
l'environnement à saint quentin en
yvelines vous faites aussi des sciences
et vous participez avec tout un mois
d'activités on va en parler à cette fête
de la science il ya des rendez-vous qui
sont proposés dès aujourd'hui et jusqu'à
ce qu'il voit depuis le début du mois
d'octobre et jusqu'à la fin et entre
autres effectivement pour le week-end à
venir puisque toutes les sciences et il
y en a partout
donc on essaye de les présenter
autrement et surtout d'aller vers les
gens d'essayer de leur montrer un peu
les sciences différemment et surtout ce
week-end donc samedi et dimanche samedi
on va s'exporter on va aller vers les
gens on va aller dans un lieu un peu
inattendu originale qui est le centre
commercial de saint quentin en yvelines
avec des animations toute la journée
entre autres des rencontres inédites est
assez insolite avec des scientifiques
on propose aux gens de
de les rencontrer de pouvoir leur poser
des questions sur leur quotidien leur
métier leur formation qu'est ce que
c'est que d'être scientifique
aujourd'hui mais aussi des animations
pour les enfants avec des expériences
des manipulations pour expliquer voilà
comment qu'est ce que les sciences et
plus particulièrement les énergies
renouvelables d'ailleurs puisque la fête
de la science à un thème qui sont les
énergies renouvelables pour tous et puis
également la cité des métiers qui seront
présents pour expliquer les différentes
filières qu'il existe dans ces domaines
là comment comment devenir scientifique
aujourd'hui quelles sont les différentes
universités qui peut vous accueillez où
les formations donc toute une journée
voilà d'animation de 9h30 jusqu'à 19
heures c'est accessible à tous c'est un
sort en face des caisses du centre
commercial voilà donc rendez vous samedi
et ça se poursuit dimanche
dimanche après midi à la maison de
l'environnement de 14 heures à 18 heures
avec notre traditionnel village des
sciences alors qu'est ce qu'un village
des sciences est justement de présenter
les différentes associations du
territoire qui vont vous présenter leur
leur métier ou leur leur passion donc on
va voir magnitude 78 par exemple qui
vont vous parler d'astronomie
on va voir météo france qui va expliquer
comment se forment les nuages entre
autres on va avoir des associations
comme la réserve naturelle également
pour expliquer justement qu'est-ce
qu'une migration pour les oiseaux quelle
énergie
elles doivent trouver pour refaire leur
migration
voilà on a un certain nombre
d'associations qui sont présents qu'on
peut aller voir les enfants peuvent
faire des animations des manipulations
des expériences à 15 heures on a un
compte qui s'appelle vent d'hiver là
aussi pour les parents et les enfants
c'est sur réservation et puis on va
finir cette joute cet après midi là avec
des expériences participatives
on va proposer aux enfants de participer
pour produire justement on va dire un
moulin à eau avec des expériences un peu
un peu particulière et originale
leur programme très complet du côté de
la maison du
de l'environnement du développement
durable et de la science voilà j'aurai
tout dit j'aurais dit les 3 mai trois
fonctions de cette maison basée à
manille l'amour à saint quentin en
yvelines
vous avez évoqué le rôle des
associations qui vont participer vous
justement est-ce que des fois des
associations se tourne vers vous
justement ce que vous avez un rapport
avec les associations du bassin saint
quentinois et ce qui est encore il faut
il faut dire que ça fait deux ans que
nous sommes installés un peu plus de
deux ans
installée sur le site mais oui je pense
que ce serait un partenariat à
développer c'est certain pour
éventuellement voilà mais ensuite
c'était des vocations alors parler de
ces rendez vous faites de la science on
va se projeter un petit peu sur les
jours d'après parce que c'est tout un
mois complet que vous consacrez la
science le thème comprenons les sciences
ce n'est pas seulement la fête de la
science aussi tout au long du mois
d'octobre des propositions dans
l'ensemble des équipements de saint
quentin en yvelines à la fois pour les
enfants pour les familles et pour les
adultes
donc pour les adultes on a quelques
propositions notamment une conférence
sur le scénario négawatt
il s'en fout il s'agit en fait
d'envisager la transition énergétique
mais aussi un cabaret politique donc
c'est une rencontre entre un
scientifique un journaliste un poète et
un philosophe qui vont parler ensemble
du thème des énergies et au niveau du
public familial tout au long du mois
d'octobre nous proposons dans les
médiathèques des ateliers avec
l'association des petits débrouillards
et des comptes donc avec une conteuse
isabelle isabelle sauvage et qui parlera
des énergies depuis l'origine de la
terre jusqu'à nos jours
ça veut dire je vous interromps qu'on
peut aborder la science par tous les
moyens par les comptes par potel rythme
était assez c'est l'objectif de
d'habitude et surtout les énergies le
thème des énergies peuvent être abordés
de différentes façons et enfin on
proposera également à la fin du mois
d'octobre
donc à partir du 25 octobre jusqu'au 31
octobre des ateliers pour les familles
sur
les énergies donc à la fois les énergies
renouvelables et les énergies non
renouvelables
c'est une manière d'aborder différentes
choses notamment le réchauffement
climatique
et puis les économies d'énergie et enfin
nous terminerons le mois de la science
par une proposition participatif chaque
habitant est invité à venir le 28
octobre à la maison de l'environnement
pour présenter des inventions des
inventions réalisées à partir des
énergies renouvelables ça peut être par
exemple une éolienne un four solaire
on proposera également à chacun de
participer à des ateliers pour réaliser
des véhicules à énergie solaire éolienne
et hydraulique à science c'est facile
finalement quand on vous entend parler
quand on entend les différents ateliers
ça peut paraître très compliqué d'aproz
mais en fait c'est très simple tout le
monde peut s'y mettre
vous avez évoqué l'association des
petits débrouillards justement vous
allez participer à ces rendez vous on a
aussi dit qu'on pouvait aborder la
science par tous les moyens possibles
c'est ce que vous faites au quotidien
avec les petits débrouillards tout à
fait nous on est on est vraiment sur une
ce qu'on appelle la démarche
expérimentale
c'est à dire que l enfant vous réalisez
pas de cours magistraux pas de cours
magistraux surtout pas et donc donc
l'enfant va réaliser lui-même
déconstruction des expériences des
manipulations donc on fait ça beaucoup
avec du matériel soit du matériel de
récupération ou du matériel de la vie de
tous les jours pour qu'ensuite l'enfant
puisse reproduire l'expérience chez lui
montra ses copains montre à sa famille
vraiment qu'ils puissent partager ce
type assure le plus les enfants les
questions qui vous pose de plus peu de
laine c'est surtout qu'on a on les
pousse à se poser encore plus de
questions c'est vraiment là notre enfin
c'est ce que ce qu'on fait ce qu'on fait
c'est vraiment que l'on préfère donner
des vins poser des questions que
d'apporter des réponses
les réponses on les construit ensemble
on teste on expérimente voit là est
toute la question tous les sujets sont
abordés
toutes les questions de paix sur tous
les sujets alors la sueur sur la fête de
la science sont nés en aidant on est
autour on va travailler autour des
énergies donc la découverte des énergies
comme d'où elles viennent qu'est-ce que
qu'est ce qu'elles peuvent permettre de
faire
comment elles sont les énergies peuvent
être transportées transformer aussi
donc voila mais autrement nos petits
débrouillards on aborde tous les sujets
qui vont de la physique de l'écologie et
puis aujourd'hui les sciences humaines
on monte des ateliers autour de l'argent
de l'économie par exemple
alors les petits débrouillards c'est une
association nationale on la perd précisé
au tout début association nationale il
ya des antennes régionales et locales
comme ici sur le sur le secteur sur le
département
elle existe depuis longtemps cette année
son département alors sur / en ile de
france l'association des petits
débrouillards en ile-de-france existe
depuis depuis une vingtaine d'années
après sur sur saint-quentin je prête à
vous dire enfin sur le set les yvelines
je me tourne vers depuis plusieurs
années on travaille déjà depuis
ouverture quasiment de la maison
environnement donc je dirais 2005 2006
voilà ouais et alors cette association
comment elle fonctionne qu il a fait
fonctionner vous on a bien compris le
mais qui êtes vous alors qu' on est bien
on est on est une association
d'éducation d'éducation populaire
partout et est donc on travaille on est
sur l'île de france on est une vingtaine
de salariés et après on travaille avec
des animateurs scientifiques conforme
et puis qui après vont animer des
ateliers donc des ateliers réguliers
dans des maisons de quartier dans des
centres de loisirs des structures de
proximité des établissements scolaires
aussi et puis après sur des
événementiels comme la fête de la
science ou dans des villes qui monte des
des projets autour des sciences bien on
est là et puis on vient faire nos
petites expériences et ne tenait ce que
tous les scientifiques peuvent parler de
science aux enfants alors à l'air de
nous les animateurs seront pas
spécifiquement scientifique c'est
vraiment des gens curieux d'abord est
donc conforme à la démarche scientifique
qui et comment on questionne dans notre
environnement ce qu'il ya autour de nous
et donc après les animateurs on
travaille avec plus de 200 animateur sur
la région d'ile-de-france qui sont
autant des étudiants alors il ya tous
les profils beaucoup d'étudiants pas ce
que c'est
c'est souvent un premier un premier
travail est la première
le première marche vers vers le travail
qui peuvent être des étudiants en
sciences mais qui peuvent eux aussi des
étudiants en arts plastiques des
étudiants en gestion fin vraiment on
trouve toutes sortes de profils
merci à toutes les quatre heures d'être
venu parler cette fête de la science
juste eu peut-être une dernière question
un mot en tout cas à propos de serge
haroche professeur au collège de france
spécialiste de la mécanique quantique
qui est le 13e scientifiques français à
recevoir le nobel de physique depuis la
création du prix en 1901
félicitations à lui est ce que justement
c'est fréquent entre stress
scientifiques français qui reçoivent ce
prix en physique on est très fort en
france je pense que c'est un milieu
râble en corse et on est content je
pense mais sais-tu la france par exemple
globalement au niveau des sciences là
c'est de la physique mais au niveau des
sciences que la france est reconnue
oui une bonne place au nez mais grâce à
ses prix nobel entre autres mais il ya
une forte
oui une forte connaissance de la science
en général et de la physique en
particulier puis ça va forcément
s'améliorer la fête de la science va
amener de nouveaux enfants qui vont
devenir verront à travailler dans les
domaines de la science merci donc à
toutes les capteurs le programme complet
est sur vos sites internet respectifs
qui se sont affichés puis si vous voulez
revoir également à cet entretien
n'oubliez pas notre site internet est
aussi prochaine rediffusion de cette
émission 19h 22h30 et minuit
il est 18h30 si vous nous suivez en
direct on va à présent parler par les
cultures dans un instant
le monde tous très émus six nations
on va pouvoir grâce à cet outil l'avoir
plusieurs niveaux de couleurs qui vont
aller du bleu très clair au rouge très
foncé et en fait donc le bleu va plutôt
correspondre à des coups à des
déperditions faible et le rouge à des
déperditions importante
malgré tout il ya un certain niveau
d'interprétation qui va être difficile à
effectuer par rapport à certains niveaux
d'un certain nature de toiture tels que
les toitures en zinc
c'est une première dans l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines
les habitants peuvent désormais
connaître la déperdition d'énergie de
leur toiture initiatives prises dans le
cadre de sa politique de développement
durable
les mesures ont été réalisées en hiver
quand les habitations sont chauffés et
par temps clair pour réaliser ces
mesures nous disposons d'un scanner
infrarouge un capteur qui nous permet de
mesurer le rayonnement infrarouge des
toitures qui est intégrée dans un avion
un avion bimoteur qui nous permet de
voler la nuit à 500 mètres d'altitude au
dessus des zones urbaines j'ai appris
que
les travaux qu'on avait fait récemment
avait servi à isoler la maison et qu'on
avait un bon résultat en termes de
déperdition de chaleur donc ça ça me
conforte un petit peu dans ce qu'on a
réalisé auparavant
les saint quentinois peuvent donc
désormais s'informer sur l'isolation
thermique de leur habitat et permanences
sont organisées les 18 et 19 octobre à
l' agence locale de l'énergie
libres à eux ensuite de se rapprocher
d'un conseiller afin de trouver des
solutions pour réduire leurs dépenses
énergétiques